Kameron voices sister is speaking out
following his sudden death hey I'm Karen
boys from descendants and you're
watching Disney Channel now that's
artwork the 20 year old descendant stars
younger sister Maya took to Instagram on
Thursday to pay tribute to her late
brother with a series of touching photos
including two sweet snaps from their
childhood and a heartbreaking letter in
honor of Camryn
who she called her best friend and
sunlight wearing shoes she also revealed
she was with her brother just hours
before his death writing in part I was
with him hours before he died it was
normal and fun we said I love you he was
happy I am devastated I will be for the
rest of my life the Disney Channel star
died on Sunday after suffering a fatal
seizure in his sleep his family and
co-stars are mourning his father debby
ryan and dove Cameron are among the many
who have spoken out in the wake of
Cameron's death Disney Channel announced
The Descendants three premiere planned
for July 22nd was canceled don't you
ever miss screaming at people and just
making them run away from you you're
thinking of my mother and I was usually
on the other end of that so not really
no Cameron was known for starring in
several Disney Channel projects
including The Descendants franchise
where he played the role of Carlos the
son of Cruella Deville
et spoke with Cameron in 2017 weeks
before the second Descendants film
debuted the first one was really big and
when we first heard about you know
doing a sequel we were like all right
how are we gonna top the first one but I
think we did I think that everything is
bigger the sets the the choreography the
numbers all of it is a really high
energy and high stakes and stuff like
that so it's pretty it's pretty fun
[Music]